[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys very important very important
to have an ironclad entrance theme and
for those of you music snobs here yes
that was track 32
rock music off of backgrounds and sound
effects volume 18 when I get the
holographic opening credit sequence done
for only two hundred and forty thousand
dollars that's gonna be kick-ass how you
guys doing good
I don't want Herman Cain to be President
but I do want to keep singing his name
in rock and pop songs from my past
that's all I do all day long I'm just
like Here I am
bana bana do not go Herman Cain that's
all I do
it's just perfect it fits everything if
you wanna hang out you gotta take her
out home Cain it's a mental illness I'm
just insane in the hurricane I've been
saying in the game nobody do you think
he'll do gain okay but don't listen to
me I'm a guy who believes that all
cookies should have last names why
because of how cool the name Fig Newton
is that is not the name of a cookie that
is the name of a 72 year old session
bassist
how you doing kids my name is Fig Newton
we heard you need some help with your
album that's why I brought along Oreo
Simmons snack well Henderson and Nutter
Butter Sansone the only white guy among
our group but trust me I'm good not a
butter can play the game triangle like
you ain't cool
but I am who are you Dan who are you
you haven't with us in yet well I am a
40-year old dude who often lingers at
CVS just to hear the end of Sharda songs
that's what that's who I am
this is a quad storm maybe I do have
time to buy mouthwash if if smooth
operator comes on I'm gonna apply for a
job here someone once told me don't put
all your eggs in one basket and I told
that person
nice try basket salesman you're not
gonna lower me with your aphorisms into
a long-term basket subscription that
should not have worked these times when
you write something on Twitter and
you're just like oh wait till I say that
through a microphone it does not work
but you rewarded me handsomely for that
leap
Cronan is an Irish name is anyone here
ever been to Ireland Ireland yeah it's
beautiful I love it I recommend going to
Ireland just to read the Irish sports
pages because they're incredibly amusing
if you don't understand sports here in
America you read the sports pages you'll
get the gist it's LA tops New York or
you know the Reds beat the Braves over
there it's just like all Flanagan grabs
a Guinea comes from time
much the Clontarf chagrin sure lilies
aplenty at Corgan blooney
as though dryer best the ragtag
Donnybrook errs was that a riddle my
read what sport was that i am a father
to seven year old twin girls they'll be
the eight this weekend and they're at
that age where they starting up really
difficult questions one of them asked me
daddy what happens when we die yeah I
didn't know what to say is this bad I
just said the pain stops
we are released of the burden that is
human existence now go to sleep one of
them use my laptop when I saw the last
thing that she googled she googled I'm
not making this up our Smurfs real and
on the one hand I was like she's
adorable
and on the other hand I was like she's
not that bright I was googling like
seven year olds Plus grasp of reality
Plus do we hold her back a year right
there are they're asking really
difficult questions I'm not making any
of these up the other one asked daddy
where is God buried
and that made me wish that I was a
conservative Republican dad because I
would had the perfect answer I just
willing where's God buried underneath
the gay liberal agenda that's where
that's where he's buried here from New
York New York yeah I hate doing your
material when I'm not your but there's
one thing I did notice that I've always
loved is that the small businesses with
all the awnings on the avenues they all
next time you go to New York every
business in New York looks like it was
named in a hurry like they had the
awning and there an hour before opening
they're just like come on we need
something okay deli
funtime corn their bagel Plaza fruit
circus I don't know all right I got I
got here there's more performers coming
up but if I meet you after the show and
you have to be a guy with a firm
handshake don't do that just just tone
it down a little bit I don't like really
firm handshakes the more the firmer you
squeeze my hand the more I assume you're
hiding from me like as you squeeze my
head I hear your secrets it's always
like how you do it Tom Wilson good to
meet you how you doing in the cross
dressing where are my wife's panties as
we speak
how you doing Tom Wilson once hit a guy
with my car and buried him in the woods
nice to meet you Tom Wilson I got 60
gigs a clown porn on my computer how you
doing Tom Wilson I'm shaking your hand
this hard to distract from the fact that
I can only get hard at the dentist I
know I thank you everybody
[Applause]